[Musica]
sono Valentina leporati ho 34 anni sono
alta un metro e 63 62 ho gli occhi verdi
sono celiaca ho il 38 di scarpe e sì
avete sentito bene Ho messo la celiachia
tra le mie particolarità ma non è sempre
stato così ci sono voluti ben 17 anni
perché io smettessi di vedere la
celiachia come un limite come un
ostacolo e lo trasformassi in
un'opportunità
vale la pena tornare indietro e
raccontare questa storia dall'inizio
sono nata qui a La Spezia in questa
perla del golfo dei Poeti famosa in
tutto il mondo per le sue meraviglie e
le sue bellezze c'è una cosa in
particolare del nostro territorio che fa
innamorare tutti e che mette tutti
d'accordo e dalla focaccia la focaccia
che viene servita a tutte le ore del
giorno in tutti i modi possibili a
colazione viene pucciata nel cappuccino
sotto gli sguardi increduli dei turisti
che non sanno che cosa si stanno
perdendo a pranzo viene servita come
accompagnamento come piatto principale
all'aperitivo arriva sui taglieri con
salumi formaggi verdure e a cena molto
spesso sostituisce la pizza farcita in
ogni modo possibile
la focaccia piace a tutti ma esclude una
particolare categoria di persone che è
quella di cui io faccio parte i celiaci
io quella focaccia non l'ho mai potuta
assaggiare perché avevo solo 17 mesi
quando sono stata diagnosticata affetta
da malattia celiaca
quindi la focaccia mi passava davanti
continuamente e io molto spesso mi
trovavo a guardare chi la mangiava con
così tanto gusto
Perché quando ero piccola piccola i miei
genitori si prendevano cura di me e
quindi tutte le differenze io non le
vedevo crescendo però mi sono accorta
che la celiachia è una malattia che c'è
sempre ma ci sono dei momenti
particolari in cui la sua presenza è
decisamente invadente e cioè i momenti
sociali quelli intorno al tavolo lì la
celiachia diventa proprio un invalidante
sociale vi faccio alcuni esempi
mi ricordo perfettamente le merende con
gli amici i compleanni in cui dovevo
sperare di trovare un tavolo con sopra
qualcosa di dedicato a me che io potessi
mangiare oppure le gite in cui dovevo
riempire lo zainetto di
crackers e merendine confezionate per
non rischiare di rimanere a digiuno
oppure a mensa Mi ricordo perfettamente
questa confezione grigia e triste sulla
quale campeggiava la scritta celiaca
nemmeno lo sforzo di scriverlo nel modo
corretto
questo nell'adolescenza è diventato un
problema perché già l'adolescenza di per
sé non è un momento facile per nessuno
se In più si è celiaci Il Faro della
diversità si accende sulla nostra testa
proprio nei momenti in cui si creano i
ricordi si costruiscono legami e si
coltiva la socialità e io lì ho fatto
l'errore più grande che potessi fare Mi
sono auto esclusa
ho costruito la mia gabbia dorata tra le
mura di casa dove mi sentivo tranquilla
e non dovevo temere di sentirmi male
davanti a qualcuno Dover raccontare
perché non stessi mangiando quindi non
andava ai compleanni
non andavo alle gite perché mi pesava
tantissimo non poter mettere nello
zainetto gli stessi vestiti alla moda
che si portavano dietro le mie amiche e
a mensa dicevo di non avere fame
stavo
Anzi non stavo vivendo l'età più
formativa probabilmente degli esseri
umani e questa cosa ce l'ho avuta Chiara
in un momento preciso e lo ricordo
perfettamente il mio compleanno dei 18
anni
l'avevo vissuto con tantissima ansia
perché ci tenevo a fare bella figura
però ancora una volta mi sono vergognata
di essere celiaca e quindi ho servito a
tutti i miei invitati
prelibatezze tradizionali con il glutine
e ho passato l'intera serata a cercare
di non farmi vedere perché non volevo
che nessuno si accorgesse che io non
stavo mangiando Poi sono successe anche
una serie di Altre sfighe che non starò
qui a raccontarvi però insomma è stata
una disfatta e io quella sera lì ho
deciso che era il momento di smetterla
così
per i miei 18 anni mi sono fatta un
regalo un regalo che ha segnato l'inizio
della mia rivoluzione mi sono tatuata
sulla spalla destra La Spiga barrata il
simbolo del senza glutine che credo
conoscerete tutti
e ho iniziato a portare in giro
quella che io ero sicura fosse la mia
diversità che è probabilmente la mia
diversità
l'ho esposta e le persone hanno iniziato
a chiedermi che cosa volesse dire quel
simbolo Tenete conto che comunque era
una ragazzina di 18 anni e al tempo non
era così comune vedere persone tatuate
era più facile vedere persone non
tatuate che tatuate quindi creavo
curiosità
e ho imparato a parlare di celiachia
senza vergognarmi senza intimirmi e
senza arrabbiarmi quando mi venivano
dette quelle frasi tipiche che ogni
celiaco almeno una volta nella vita si è
sentito dire ma se mangi il pane e muori
ma poi ti passa vero ma se ti lancio una
briciola cosa ti succede
Ecco questo i celiaci stanno bene che
succede a tutti però nelle persone
quando rispondevo non notavo più pena o
ho paura anche a volte notavo curiosità
apertura
e da lì la mia vita è cambiata da così a
così è iniziato un circolo virtuoso che
mi ha portato ad aprire un panificio
completamente senza glutine e nello
stesso tempo ho iniziato a parlare sui
social di celiachia perché il pensiero è
stato se posso essere utile anche solo
ad una persona dall'altra parte dello
schermo a sentirsi accolta abbracciata e
compresa Allora tutto questo avrà avuto
un senso tutta la sofferenza che ho
passato
sarà stata utile a qualcuno e avrò
evitato che qualcun altro facesse il mio
stesso errore
ho avuto delle Armi benevole dalla mia
parte e sono state la conoscenza della
malattia e della cucina senza glutine
che mi permettono di maneggiare la mia
condizione e di cucinare perlibatezze
che non fanno rimpiangere quelle
tradizionali disinnescando quell'idea
per la quale il senza glutine non è
appetibile poi l'autoironia che mi
permette di parlare di celiachia senza
mettere in piedi un comizio che potrebbe
annoiare molte persone anzi molto spesso
invece riesco ad incuriosirle e poi le
emozioni
perché le emozioni permettono a tutti di
indossare i panni della persona che ti
sta ti sta raccontando la sua storia
te la fa vivere
le emozioni permettono di trasformare
una diversità in particolarità perché
Pensateci io sono sicura che ognuno di
noi almeno una volta nella vita si è
sentito diverso per un qualsiasi motivo
ci sentiamo diversi perché non possiamo
mangiare quello che mangiano gli altri
ci sentiamo diversi perché magari
dobbiamo trasferirci in un posto nuovo
di cui non conosciamo usi abitudini e
forse anche linguaggio ci sentiamo
diversi per un nostro gusto che alla
fine lo specchio di quello che siamo e
quindi ci sentiamo diversi anche solo
per il fatto di essere esattamente
quello che siamo tutti almeno una volta
abbiamo vissuto questo e quindi ho
capito che raccontare la mia storia in
modo emozionale avrebbe permesso alle
persone di indossare le mie scarpe fare
una parte del mio percorso con me anche
se la mia condizione non li toccava
tanti non sono celiaci Eppure indossano
i miei panni e si prendono a cuore la
mia battaglia
perché non è la battaglia del singolo
a fare la differenza è la battaglia
comune
parlo di emozioni sui social perché
credo sia davvero la strada giusta per
costruire un mondo più inclusivo più
gentile
dove c'è gentilezza c'è empatia ci
abbraccio
e io da parte mia vi prometto che
continuerò a combattere a fare di tutto
perché questo davvero si possa costruire
da parte mia vi prometto che continuerò
a metterci la faccia per costruire un
mondo più inclusivo più gentile più
comprensivo un mondo in cui nessuno mai
più debba sentirsi escluso
[Applauso]